This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. When Joseph Weisenbaum was still alive, he'd like to tell the story about a computer program he'd created back in the 1960s as a professor at MIT. It was a simple chatbot named Eliza that could interact with users in a typed conversation. Weisenbaum asked his secretary to try it out. I asked her to my office and sat it down at the keyboard and then she began to type and of course I looked over her shoulder to make sure that everything was operating properly. Wizenbaum watched as the secretary typed a message to Eliza and then as the program responded to her. After two or three interchanges with the machine she turned to me and she said, would you mind leaving the room, please? The secretary was so entranced by this chatbot
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马斯。约瑟夫·魏岑鲍姆在世时，很喜欢讲一个关于他在20世纪60年代担任麻省理工学院教授期间所开发程序的故事。那是一个名为“伊莉莎”（Eliza）的简单聊天机器人，可以通过打字与用户进行互动。魏岑鲍姆让他的秘书试用一下。“我请她到我的办公室，让她坐在键盘前，然后她开始打字。当然，我站在她身后，确保一切运行正常。”魏岑鲍姆看着秘书给伊莉莎发了一条信息，然后程序做出了回应。在与机器进行了两三次交流后，她转过身对我说：“你介意离开房间吗？”秘书被这个聊天机器人深深吸引了，
that she didn't want to stop exchanging messages. Weisenbaum's secretary fell under the spell of the machine. Weisenbaum saw this happening over and over again. People would reveal very intimate details about their lives to the program. It was like they'd just been waiting for someone, for something to ask. Eliza was a simple computer program.
以至于她不想停止发送信息。魏岑鲍姆的秘书被这台机器迷住了。魏岑鲍姆一次又一次地看到这种情况发生。人们会向程序透露他们生活中非常私密的细节。就好像他们一直在等待某人、某事来询问一样。伊莉莎只是一个简单的计算机程序。
That's producer Delaney Hall. The way it worked was it would recognize a keyword in the user's statement, and then reflect it back in the form of a simple phrase or question. When Eliza got confused or couldn't parse a statement, it would fall back on set phrases like, please go on or tell me more. Why's and bomb had programmed Eliza to interact in the style of a psychotherapist, and it
那是制片人德莱尼·霍尔。它的工作原理是识别用户陈述中的关键词，然后以简单的短语或问题的形式将其反射回来。当伊莉莎感到困惑或无法解析陈述时，它会退回到预设的短语，比如“请继续”或“多告诉我一些”。魏岑鲍姆将伊莉莎编程为以心理治疗师的风格进行互动，而且
was pretty convincing. It gave the illusion of empathy even though it was just simple code. Here is an exchange, dramatized in an all-documentary segment. It begins with the human. Men are all alike. And then the computer program answers. In what way? They're always bugging us about something or other. Can you think of a specific example? Well, my boyfriend made me come here. Your boyfriend made you come here. He says, I'm depressed much the time. I'm sorry to hear that you're depressed. It's true. I am unhappy.
它非常有说服力。尽管它只是简单的代码，却营造出了一种同理心的错觉。这是一段在纪录片片段中戏剧化的对话。它以人类的话语开始：“男人都一样。”然后计算机程序回答：“在什么方面？”“他们总是因为这样或那样的事情烦我们。”“你能想到一个具体的例子吗？”“嗯，我男朋友非要我来这里。”“你男朋友非要你来这里。”“他说，我大部分时间都很沮丧。”“听到你很沮丧，我很遗憾。”“是真的。我很不开心。”
Do you think coming here will help you not to be unhappy? Eliza was one of the very first computer programs that could convincingly simulate human conversation. And Wizenbaum got weirded out by the way that people reacted to it. He didn't expect them to be so captivated. He feared that they were being fooled, that they didn't really understand it was just a bunch of circuits on the other end. And he wondered if it was so easy to mimic a sense of human understanding, then what
“你认为来这里会有助于你不再不开心吗？”伊莉莎是第一批能够令人信服地模拟人类对话的计算机程序之一。魏岑鲍姆对人们的反应感到不安。他没想到他们会如此着迷。他担心他们被愚弄了，担心他们并没有真正理解对方只是一堆电路。他想，如果模仿人类的理解感如此容易，那么
did that say about human understanding? Weisenbaum started raising these big, difficult questions at a time when the field of artificial intelligence was still relatively new and mostly filled with optimism. Many researchers dreamed of creating a world where humans and technology merged in new ways. They wanted to create computers that could talk with us and respond to our needs and desires. But Wizenbaum would take a different path. He would begin to speak out against what he saw as the eroding boundary between humans and machines.
这说明了什么关于人类理解的问题？魏岑鲍姆在人工智能领域还相对较新且充满乐观情绪的时候，提出了这些宏大而困难的问题。许多研究人员梦想创造一个人类与技术以新方式融合的世界。他们想创造出能与我们交谈并响应我们需求和欲望的计算机。但魏岑鲍姆选择了不同的道路。他开始公开反对他所认为的人类与机器之间日益模糊的界限。
And he'd eventually break from the artificial intelligentsia, becoming one of the first and loudest critics of the technology he helped to build. People have long been fascinated with mechanical devices that imitate humans. Ancient Egyptians built statues of divinities from wood and stone and consulted them for advice. Early Buddhist scholars described precious metal people that would recite sacred texts and weep. Oh, the Greeks had a wonderful attitude toward robots and machines. They welcomed them. This is Pamela McCordick, and she wrote Machines Who Think, one of the first modern histories of artificial intelligence.
他最终与人工智能界决裂，成为他所帮助建立的这项技术的第一批、也是最响亮的批评者之一。长期以来，人们一直对模仿人类的机械装置着迷。古埃及人曾用木头和石头建造神像，并向它们寻求建议。早期的佛教僧侣描述过会背诵经文并流泪的贵金属人。“哦，希腊人对机器人和机器有着极好的态度。他们欢迎它们。”这是帕梅拉·麦科德克，她撰写了《思考的机器》，这是现代人工智能史上的第一部著作之一。
And she says that in Greek mythology, the God Hephaestus, who was the God of blacksmithing, loved to make robots. He created all kinds of robots, and one to help him out in the forge, and all kinds of party help. You know, things would roll into the parties of the gods with trays and whatnot. And there's a wonderful description in Homer.
她说，在希腊神话中，锻造之神赫淮斯托斯喜欢制造机器人。他制造了各种各样的机器人，有的在锻造炉里帮他忙，还有各种各样的宴会助手。你知道，那些东西会带着托盘之类的东西滚进众神的宴会。荷马史诗中对此有精彩的描述。
They are like lovely young women, and there is intelligence in their hearts. Flash forward nearly 2500 years to the 1940s. In the mid-1940s, the 20th century had different kind of tool within Ben. A tool for extending certain of the powers of man, mind. This tool is the electronic computer. But this tool is the electronic computer. As modern computers became more powerful and widely available, people began to believe that this fantasy of intelligent machines that could think and communicate might actually be within grasp.
“它们就像可爱的年轻女子，心中有智慧。”时间快进近2500年，来到20世纪40年代。在20世纪40年代中期，20世纪拥有了一种不同类型的工具。一种用于扩展人类某些思维能力的工具。这个工具就是电子计算机。但这个工具就是电子计算机。随着现代计算机变得越来越强大且广泛可用，人们开始相信，这种能够思考和交流的智能机器的幻想可能真的触手可及。
The idea was most famously articulated by the British mathematician Alan Turing. And he wrote this very famous paper in 1950, called Computing, Machinery, and Intelligence, which begins with this famous line, Ken Machines Think. This is Brian Christian. He wrote the most human human, what talking with computers teaches us
这个想法最著名的阐述者是英国数学家艾伦·图灵。他在1950年写了一篇非常著名的论文，题为《计算机器与智能》，开头就是那句名言：“机器能思考吗？”这是布莱恩·克里斯蒂安。他写了《最像人的人：与计算机交谈教会我们》
about what it means to be alive. Turin is already sort of seeing ahead into the 21st century and imagining what if someday we do manage to build a machine that can actually quote unquote think, how would we know that we had built such a machine? This is a hard task because it's difficult to even define what it means to think, let alone prove that a computer is doing it. But Turing approached the question like the engineer he was, proposing a simple test.
“关于活着意味着什么。”图灵已经在某种程度上预见了21世纪，并想象如果有一天我们真的设法制造出一台能够“引用”思考的机器，我们怎么知道我们已经制造出了这样一台机器呢？这是一项艰巨的任务，因为甚至很难定义“思考”意味着什么，更不用说证明计算机正在这样做。但图灵像他那样的工程师一样处理这个问题，提出了一个简单的测试。
He said that if a computer could regularly fool people into thinking it was, in fact, a human, it would pass. Turing predicted that this would eventually happen so consistently. That as a result, we would just, as a society, he says, come to this point where we would speak of machines as being intelligent without expecting to be contradicted. The Turin Test brought up really profound questions. One's we've been thinking about since the days of Greek robots and precious metal people. What does it mean to have a mind? How do you kind of bridge that gap from one mind to another? And is language kind of the best
他说，如果一台计算机能经常愚弄人们，让他们认为它实际上是一个人，那么它就通过了测试。图灵预测，这种情况最终会如此频繁地发生，以至于结果就是，作为一个社会，他说，我们会达到这样一个地步：我们会谈论机器是智能的，而不指望有人反驳。图灵测试提出了非常深刻的问题。这些问题自希腊机器人和贵金属人时代以来我们就一直在思考。拥有思想意味着什么？你如何弥合从一个思想通往另一个思想的鸿沟？语言是最好的
or only means that we have for doing that. How does empathy work? What are the limits of empathy? They're not fundamentally technological questions. They're fundamentally human questions. And there are questions that would come to occupy Joseph Weisenbaum, the creator of Alisa. Before turning against artificial intelligence,
或者是我们拥有的唯一手段吗？同理心是如何运作的？同理心的局限性是什么？这些不是根本上的技术问题。它们是根本上的人类问题。这些问题最终占据了伊莉莎的创造者约瑟夫·魏岑鲍姆的思绪。在反对人工智能之前，
Weisenbaum helped develop it. He was part of an early generation of AI researchers. Back in the 50s, they started exploring how to give computers new human-like powers. They programmed computers to reason, plan, and perceive. They created programs that could play checkers, solve word problems, and prove logical theorems. The press at the time described their work as astonishing.
魏岑鲍姆帮助开发了它。他是早期人工智能研究人员的一代。早在50年代，他们就开始探索如何赋予计算机类似人类的新能力。他们编写程序让计算机进行推理、计划和感知。他们创造了可以玩跳棋、解决文字问题和证明逻辑定理的程序。当时的媒体将他们的工作描述为“令人惊叹”。
Herb Simon, one of the most prominent AI researchers at the time, predicted that within 20 years, by the 1980s, machines would be capable of doing any work a person could do. Just like today, these advances made people pretty anxious. For millennia, humans had to find themselves as rational creatures. It was our ability to reason and use logic and play chess that made us special. It is exactly those things that the computer came in
赫伯·西蒙，当时最著名的人工智能研究人员之一，预测在20年内，即到20世纪80年代，机器将能够完成人能做的任何工作。就像今天一样，这些进步让人们感到非常焦虑。几千年来，人类将自己定义为理性的生物。正是我们推理、使用逻辑和下棋的能力使我们变得特别。而正是这些东西，计算机介入了，
and, you know, within a handful of years was better than any human could ever hope to be. And so it really pulled that rug out from under us. But despite all the big leaps forward, there was one realm in particular where computers remained quite dumb. They struggled to master human language, which is known in AI as natural language. Natural language processing or understanding, if you will, is probably the hardest problem for AI. Melanie Mitchell is a computer scientist and AI researcher. When we communicate in language, we're using all of our thought processes.
并且，你知道，在短短几年内就比任何人类所能希望达到的水平都要好。所以它确实把我们脚下的地毯抽走了。但尽管有所有这些巨大的飞跃，有一个领域计算机仍然相当笨拙。它们努力掌握人类语言，这在人工智能中被称为自然语言。自然语言处理或理解，如果你愿意的话，可能是人工智能最难的问题。梅兰妮·米切尔是一位计算机科学家和人工智能研究人员。“当我们用语言交流时，我们正在使用我们所有的思维过程。”
We're using our vast knowledge of the way the world works, about other people and their goals and motivations. We're disambiguating words. It's really almost equivalent to cognition itself. So as an example of this, Mitchell says, think about this sentence. A steel ball fell on a glass table and it shattered. If you ask, what does it refer to? Humans will understand immediately. Of course, we know that if a steel ball falls on a glass table, the glass table shatters. But that's because we know about what glass is, what steel is, we know about things falling
“我们正在利用我们关于世界运作方式、关于他人及其目标和动机的丰富知识。我们正在消除词语的歧义。这几乎等同于认知本身。”作为一个例子，米切尔说，想想这个句子：“一个钢球掉在玻璃桌子上，它碎了。”如果你问，“它”指的是什么？人类会立即理解。当然，我们知道如果钢球掉在玻璃桌子上，玻璃桌子会碎。但那是因为我们知道什么是玻璃，什么是钢，我们知道物体掉落
on other things, and we know a lot about the way the world works. But computers don't know that stuff. Unless they're programmed to, they don't actually know about glass and steel and gravity. And actually programming all that information into a computer is really labor intensive and difficult because that knowledge is mostly subconscious for us. It's so intuitive as to be almost invisible. And this is something that comes up again and again in natural language processing systems is that they don't have the kind of
在其他物体上，我们对世界的运作方式了解很多。但计算机不知道这些东西。除非它们被编程，否则它们实际上并不了解玻璃、钢和重力。而且，将所有这些信息编程到计算机中确实非常费力且困难，因为这些知识对我们来说大多是潜意识的。它是如此直观，以至于几乎是隐形的。这是自然语言处理系统中反复出现的问题，即它们没有那种
knowledge about the world that we humans have, and so they make mistakes. This clumsiness with human language meant that early chatbots built in the 1950s and 60s were tightly constrained. They could converse about some very specific topic, like, say, baseball, so you could ask about Joe DiMaggio's batting average in 1949, and the computer would tell you. And by limiting the world of possible questions and answers, researchers could build machines that passed as intelligent.
我们人类所拥有的关于世界的知识，所以它们会犯错。这种在人类语言上的笨拙意味着20世纪50年代和60年代制造的早期聊天机器人受到了严格限制。它们可以谈论一些非常具体的话题，比如，棒球，所以你可以询问乔·迪马乔1949年的打击率，计算机就会告诉你。通过限制可能的问题和答案的范围，研究人员可以制造出看起来很智能的机器。
But talking with them was like having a conversation with Wikipedia, not a real person. I was very aware of the notion that he was doing something with computers that gave these computers a power to understand that was leaps and bounds above anything that had come before. Naomi Weisenbaum is Joseph Weisenbaum's youngest daughter. She didn't know a lot about the specifics of his work when she was growing up, but she remembers his mustache, she says he always had one, and that he was serious and studious, and he spent a lot of time in his office at home. My mother, she'd call me downstairs and say, okay, time to go walk the dad, and I had to
但与它们交谈就像与维基百科对话，而不是与一个真实的人。我非常清楚这样一个概念：他正在用计算机做一些事情，赋予这些计算机一种远超以往任何东西的理解能力。娜奥米·魏岑鲍姆是约瑟夫·魏岑鲍姆最小的女儿。她在成长过程中对父亲工作的具体细节了解不多，但她记得他的胡子，她说他总是留着胡子，而且他很严肃、好学，他在家里的书房里花了很多时间。“我母亲会叫我下楼说，‘好了，该去遛爸爸了’，我不得不”
go down and fetch dad out of his study and ask him to come for a walk with me. She also remembers her dad as someone who couldn't help but see the world from a critical perspective. I think my father was very deeply an outsider right from the very beginning and that when he went to MIT, it was no exception. Shortly after he arrived at MIT in the 1960s, Weisenbaum had an insight.
下楼把爸爸从书房里叫出来，让他陪我散步。她还记得她的父亲是一个无法不从批判的角度看世界的人。“我认为我的父亲从一开始就是一个彻头彻尾的局外人，当他去麻省理工学院时，也不例外。”20世纪60年代初，魏岑鲍姆刚到麻省理工学院不久，就产生了一个洞察。
He realized he could create a clever workaround for the natural language problem. He could build a chatbot that didn't really need to know anything about anything. It wouldn't spin out facts. It would just reflect back at you, like a mirror. You know, the cocktail party conversation, for example. This is Joseph Weisenbaum in an archival interview. Where someone says something to you that you really don't fully understand, but you are, in fact, able to give an response, which appears appropriate, and in fact, the conversation continues for quite a long time.
他意识到他可以为自然语言问题创造一个巧妙的变通方法。他可以建立一个根本不需要了解任何事情的聊天机器人。它不会吐出事实。它只会像镜子一样把你所说的反射回来。你知道，比如鸡尾酒会上的谈话。这是约瑟夫·魏岑鲍姆在一次档案采访中所说的：“当有人对你说了一些你并没有完全理解的话，但你实际上能够给出一个看起来恰当的回应，事实上，谈话持续了很长时间。”
And we do that all the time. You. And we do that all the time. We do that all time. But why's a mom still had to create a framework in which that conversation would happen? A style of interaction the program could follow. Why's a mom had long been interested in psychology and he recognized that the speech patterns of a therapist might be easy to automate. Because when you think of a therapist, certain phrases come to mind. Like, and how does that make you feel? And so, why's a man decided to create a bot that, like, a therapist would listen, pick out keywords, and then mirror statements back to the user?
“我们一直都在这样做。”“我们一直都在这样做。”“我们一直都在这样做。”但魏岑鲍姆仍然必须创建一个对话发生的框架。一种程序可以遵循的互动风格。魏岑鲍姆长期以来一直对心理学感兴趣，他认识到治疗师的言语模式可能很容易自动化。因为当你想到治疗师时，某些短语就会浮现在脑海中。比如，“那让你感觉如何？”所以，魏岑鲍姆决定创建一个机器人，像治疗师一样倾听，挑选出关键词，然后将陈述反射回用户。
How dad explained it was that it was kind of simple, simple psychology, more or less very similar to a parent, that you pick out one element of what the person said and you ask them to expand on that. Joseph Weisenbaum was very clear. He didn't intend for Eliza to be an actual therapeutic tool. It wasn't even programmed with information about human thought or emotion, but nevertheless Eliza seemed to understand. And as Weisenbaum watched people like his secretary
“爸爸解释说，这是一种简单的心理学，或多或少非常类似于父母，你挑选出对方所说的一个元素，然后要求他们对此进行扩展。”约瑟夫·魏岑鲍姆非常明确。他并不打算让伊莉莎成为一种实际的治疗工具。它甚至没有被编程关于人类思想或情感的信息，但尽管如此，伊莉莎似乎还是理解了。当魏岑鲍姆看着像他秘书那样的人
converse with the program, he quickly realized they weren't just having simple, dimple exchanges. They were having meaningful conversations with the machine. People began having these really long, kind of soul-bearing conversations with this program and reporting, you know, a meaningful therapeutic experience. And this, for him, was horrific. Brian Christian again.
与程序交谈时，他很快意识到他们不仅仅是在进行简单的交流。他们正在与机器进行有意义的对话。人们开始与这个程序进行这些非常漫长的、某种程度上是倾诉心声的对话，并报告说，你知道，这是一种有意义的治疗体验。对他来说，这太可怕了。布莱恩·克里斯蒂安再次说道。
He talks about, you know, I would have assumed that, you know, some sort of meaningful experience like this would require someone to be present on the other side of the conversation and to actually invest something. So the fact that the nearest mechanical parity of this process can still apparently produce something meaningful for people, he found really unsettling. But while Weisenbaum was horrified by his own creation, others saw Eliza as an important breakthrough and a real opportunity. Before coming to MIT, Wizenbaum had spent time at Stanford, where he became friends with a psychiatrist named Dr. Kenneth Colby. Colby had worked at a large underfunded state mental hospital,
“他谈到，你知道，我本以为，某种像这样的有意义的体验需要有人在对话的另一端，并且真正投入一些东西。所以，这种过程的机械对等物仍然显然能为人们产生有意义的东西，这一事实让他感到非常不安。”但虽然魏岑鲍姆对自己的创造感到恐惧，但其他人却将伊莉莎视为一个重要的突破和一个真正的机会。在来到麻省理工学院之前，魏岑鲍姆曾在斯坦福大学待过一段时间，在那里他与一位名叫肯尼斯·科尔比博士的精神科医生成为了朋友。科尔比曾在一家资金不足的大型州立精神病院工作，
where patients may be saw a therapist once a month. And that was why when he encountered even this rather crude caricature as Wyzenbaum put it, of the therapeutic process, he thought, boy, I can put some therapeutic knowledge into this and make it happen. Colby started promoting the idea that Eliza might actually be therapeutically useful and the medical community started to pay attention. They thought maybe this program or other programs like it could help expand access to mental health care.
那里的病人可能一个月才见一次治疗师。这就是为什么当他遇到这种魏岑鲍姆所说的“治疗过程的粗糙讽刺画”时，他想：“天哪，我可以把一些治疗知识放进去，让它实现。”科尔比开始推广伊莉莎可能具有治疗用途的想法，医学界开始关注。他们认为也许这个程序或其他类似的程序可以帮助扩大心理健康服务的获取途径。
And maybe in some ways, it could even be better than a human therapist. It would be cheaper and people might actually speak more freely with a robot. Yeah, I can tell this. A bunch of tubes, anything I want. I can tell the truth.
也许在某些方面，它甚至可能比人类治疗师更好。它会更便宜，而且人们可能真的会更自由地与机器人交谈。“是的，我可以告诉这个。一堆管子，任何我想说的话。我可以讲真话。”
We feel free to open ourselves to what we think is a non-judgmental machine. Many therapists claim there has to be a live warm human body present for a therapeutic change to take place. Again, that's an opinion that's not a fact. Here's Colby in a news interview years later. If you say to the program, I'm feeling quite depressed, I would sympathize with you and so will the machine.
“我们感到可以自由地向我们认为是非评判性的机器敞开心扉。”许多治疗师声称，必须有一个活生生的、温暖的人体在场才能发生治疗性的改变。同样，这是一种观点，而不是事实。这是科尔比多年后在新闻采访中所说的：“如果你对程序说，‘我感到很沮丧’，我会同情你，机器也会。”
So the idea of the robot therapist started to take off. You know, in the late 60s, early 70s, you have these peer-reviewed psychology journal articles saying, you know, this represents a potential breakthrough for therapy. The famed scientist Carl Sagan wrote about the idea in 1975, imagining a network of psychotherapeutic computer terminals, kind of like phone booths. You walk to a city corner, put a nickel,
所以机器人治疗师的想法开始流行起来。你知道，在60年代末、70年代初，你会有这些经过同行评审的心理学期刊文章说，你知道，这代表了治疗的一个潜在突破。著名科学家卡尔·萨根在1975年写到了这个想法，想象了一个心理治疗计算机终端网络，有点像电话亭。你走到城市角落，投进一个镍币，
and you talk to this therapeutic robot for a few minutes to kind of take your mind off of things, so it's very warmly received by the medical community at large. And while the idea of therapy terminals on every corner never materialized, people who worked in mental health would continue to experiment with how to use computers in their work. Colby, for instance, went on to create another chatbot called Perry, which simulated the conversational style of a person with paranoid schizophrenia. He later developed a program called Overcoming Depression.
然后你和这个治疗机器人交谈几分钟，以某种方式把你的心思从烦恼中转移出来，所以它受到了医学界的热烈欢迎。虽然在每个角落都有治疗终端的想法从未实现，但从事心理健康工作的人们继续尝试如何在他们的工作中使用计算机。例如，科尔比后来创造了另一个名为“佩里”（Perry）的聊天机器人，它模拟了一个患有偏执型精神分裂症的人的对话风格。他后来开发了一个名为“克服抑郁”的程序。
Again, for Wizenbaum, he felt like he had sort of let this genie out of the bottle and there was kind of no going back. The real greek or the real controversy, finally it was over at the claim that Eliza was of therapeutic significance. You know, my God, could people really believe that? And what are we doing? Why is Embaum objected to the idea that something as subtle, intimate, and human as therapy could be reduced to code. He worried that if machines snuck into the therapist's office, then where else might
同样，对于魏岑鲍姆来说，他觉得他好像把这个精灵从瓶子里放了出来，而且有点无法回头了。真正的争议，最终是关于伊莉莎具有治疗意义的说法。“天哪，人们真的能相信吗？我们在做什么？”魏岑鲍姆反对将像治疗这样微妙、亲密和人性化的东西简化为代码的想法。他担心如果机器溜进治疗师的办公室，那么它们还可能
they end up? He began to argue that fields requiring human compassion and understanding just shouldn't be automated. Why Zimbabm also worried about the same future that Alan Turing had described. One were chatbots regularly fooled people into thinking they were interacting with a human. Wizenbaum would write a valyzer, quote, but I had not realized is that extremely short exposures to a relatively simple computer program could induce powerful delusional thinking
出现在哪里？他开始争论说，需要人类同情心和理解的领域根本不应该被自动化。魏岑鲍姆还担心艾伦·图灵所描述的同一个未来。一个聊天机器人经常愚弄人们，让他们认为他们正在与一个人互动。魏岑鲍姆写道：“但我没有意识到的是，极短时间接触一个相对简单的计算机程序就能诱发相当正常的人产生强大的妄想思维。”
in quite normal people. The whole thing is a con job. The whole thing is, it's very much like fortune telling. It's an illusion-qureating machine and all that sort of thing. Wizenbaum quickly went from someone working in the heart of the AI community at MIT to someone preaching against it. And his friend Kenneth Colby became one of his first targets. He began attacking Dr. Colby in public, in professional meetings. And he would say this is a wicked thing to do.
“整件事是一场骗局。整件事，它非常像算命。它是一台制造幻觉的机器，诸如此类。”魏岑鲍姆很快从一个在麻省理工学院人工智能社区核心工作的人变成了一个反对它的人。他的朋友肯尼斯·科尔比成了他的首要目标之一。他开始在公共场合、专业会议上攻击科尔比博士。他会说这是一件邪恶的事情，
It should not be done, and he should be punished for doing it. Over time, Wiesenbaum escalated his arguments. His family had escaped Nazi Germany in 1936, and sometimes when critiquing AI, Wiesenbaum would invoke the Holocaust. He worried powerful technologies could be abused by governments and corporations. Here's one of his other daughters, Miriam Wiesenbaum. These happen to be incredibly powerful tools, and the really important question is, for whom are they being used? What's the purpose of them? Who benefits?
“不应该这样做，他应该因为这样做而受到惩罚。”随着时间的推移，魏岑鲍姆升级了他的论点。他的家人在1936年逃离了纳粹德国，有时在批评人工智能时，魏岑鲍姆会援引大屠杀。他担心强大的技术会被政府和公司滥用。这是他的另一个女儿，米里亚姆·魏岑鲍姆。“这些恰好是极其强大的工具，真正重要的问题是，它们是为谁使用的？它们的目的是什么？谁受益？”
Who's subject to them? Who controls them? Who doesn't? At that point, he began extending that and saying all artificial intelligence is questionable and probably wicked. It shouldn't be done. And, uh, oh dear, he was really swimming upstream on that one. The computers are coming.
“谁受制于它们？谁控制它们？谁不控制？”在那一点上，他开始扩展并说所有人工智能都是可疑的，而且可能是邪恶的。它不应该被做。而且，哦天哪，他在那方面真的是逆流而上。计算机来了。
Well, the next few decades, AI allowed for automation not just in therapy, but in fields like medicine, law, and finance. Computers fly our planes. Increasingly, they do our banking. The computer is king, business, finance, and information. And increasingly, say experts, computers will get smarter and smarter. Companions, advisors, articles, to all of us. Eventually, researchers began trying
好吧，接下来的几十年里，人工智能不仅在治疗领域，而且在医学、法律和金融等领域实现了自动化。计算机驾驶我们的飞机。它们越来越多地处理我们的银行业务。计算机是商业、金融和信息领域的国王。而且专家们说，计算机将变得越来越聪明。同伴、顾问，对我们所有人来说。最终，研究人员开始尝试
to create computers that were flexible enough to learn human language on their own. To take those first faltering steps, as babies do, toward understanding language, to break down and diagram sentences, to remember new meanings, verb tenses, and to ask questions to make itself smarter. The computer wants to know, is the past tense of make, mate, knows, as Martin, may. These programs could take a long time to figure things out.
创造足够灵活的计算机，能够自己学习人类语言。像婴儿一样迈出那些蹒跚的第一步，走向理解语言，分解和图解句子，记住新的含义、动词时态，并提出问题使自己变得更聪明。计算机想知道，“make”的过去式是“mate”吗？知道，就像马丁，“may”。这些程序可能需要很长时间才能弄清楚事情。
It has been a tedious three-year project. The computer now knows about 300 words. Still, Paul Martin is convinced computers can learn. But starting in the 1980s and 90s, there were new breakthroughs in natural language processing. Scientists began relying on statistical methods. Taking documents or recordings of language and performing statistics on things like, how often does one word come after another? Or how often does this sort of triplet of words occur? And then in the 2000s and 2010s, researchers began using
“这是一个乏味的三年的项目。计算机现在认识大约300个单词。”尽管如此，保罗·马丁确信计算机可以学习。但从20世纪80年代和90年代开始，自然语言处理取得了新的突破。科学家们开始依赖统计方法。获取语言的文档或录音，并对诸如“一个词出现在另一个词之后的频率是多少？”或“这种词的三元组出现的频率是多少？”之类的事情进行统计。然后在2000年代和2010年代，研究人员开始使用
what are called deep neural networks. They're trained using the huge amounts of data that only became possible with the rise of the internet. So now we can take every single web page online and process the language in it and have the neural network analyze the language. And they work so much better than anything that came before. And these techniques, Mitchell, is describing they've been applied to chatbots specifically. They might be trained on actual conversations, recorded conversations. Sometimes people put their chatbot online and then other people interact with them and the systems learn by just interacting with people online. As a result, contemporary chatbots and their talking cousins like Siri and Alexa have gotten a lot better.
所谓的深度神经网络。它们使用只有在互联网兴起后才成为可能的海量数据进行训练。所以现在我们可以获取在线的每一个网页，处理其中的语言，并让神经网络分析语言。它们比以前的任何东西都要好得多。米切尔描述的这些技术已经被专门应用于聊天机器人。它们可能是在实际对话、录音对话上进行训练的。有时人们把他们的聊天机器人放在网上，然后其他人与它们互动，系统通过与在线的人互动来学习。结果，当代聊天机器人及其像Siri和Alexa这样的会说话的表亲们已经变得好多了。
There are still limitations, of course. They still can't really understand the world in the same way we do, but they have become a lot more reliable, personable, and convincing. And humans remain as open and sometimes gullible as ever when it comes to interacting with chatbots. There's even a term that's emerged in computer science. The Eliza effect that refers to our tendency to anthropomorphize computers and to believe that programs understand, even when they really don't. There are recent examples that make it feel as though we are living firmly in the world that Alan Turing predicted and that Joseph Weisenbaum feared. Machines full humans all the time now.
当然，仍然存在局限性。它们仍然不能像我们一样真正理解世界，但它们已经变得更加可靠、有个性且令人信服。当涉及到与聊天机器人互动时，人类仍然像以往一样开放，有时甚至容易受骗。计算机科学中甚至出现了一个术语：伊莉莎效应，指的是我们倾向于将计算机拟人化，并相信程序理解，即使它们实际上并不理解。最近的例子让我们感觉我们正坚定地生活在艾伦·图灵预测和约瑟夫·魏岑鲍姆恐惧的世界中。机器现在一直在愚弄人类。
In 2018, for example, Google revealed something called Duplex, a conversational AI that can make phone reservations. and it is uncanny. So how's my out here? Hi, I'm calling to book a women's hair cut for our client. I'm looking for something on May 3rd. You are a wood timeer, are you looking for around at 12 p.m. They programmed in human like stuttering and saying, um, and, uh, and made it very convincing. Do you have anything between 10 a.m. and 12 p.m. Depending on what service she would like, what service is she looking for? Just a woman's haircut for now.
例如，2018年，谷歌展示了一种名为Duplex的东西，这是一种可以进行电话预约的对话式人工智能。它非常不可思议。“那么，我在这里做什么？”“嗨，我打电话来为我们的客户预订女士理发。我在找5月3日的时间。”“你是木工吗，你在找12点左右的时间吗？”他们编程了类似人类的结巴和说“嗯”、“啊”，并使它非常有说服力。“你有上午10点到12点之间的任何时间吗？”“取决于她想要什么服务，她在找什么服务？”“暂时只是女士理发。”
They sounded very human. People were really alarmed. They wanted to know that they were speaking to a computer. The first name is Lisa. Okay, perfect. So I will see Lisa at 10 o'clock on May 3rd. This issue of transparency has become central to the ethical design of these kinds of systems, especially in sensitive realms like therapy.
它们听起来非常像人。人们真的很惊慌。他们想知道他们是在与计算机交谈。“名字是丽莎。”“好的，太完美了。那么我会在5月3日10点见到丽莎。”这个问题透明度已成为这些系统伦理设计的核心，特别是在像治疗这样敏感的领域。
Because even if Eliza was the first chatbot to be used in the field of mental health, it wasn't the last. Transparency is the basis of trust and you must have trust with a service like this. This is Allison Darcy. My name is Allison Darcy. I'm the CEO and founder of WoBot Labs. Darcy is a psychologist and she's long been interested in how to use digital tools to expand access to mental health care. In the United States, the third of the population are living in areas that are designated no access areas, so they effectively don't have a mental health professional anywhere near them. And even if you live in a major city with lots of therapists, it's often not covered by insurance and can be super expensive.
因为即使伊莉莎是第一个在心理健康领域使用的聊天机器人，它也不是最后一个。“透明度是信任的基础，你必须对这样的服务有信任。”这是艾莉森·达西。“我的名字是艾莉森·达西。我是WoBot Labs的首席执行官和创始人。”达西是一位心理学家，她长期以来一直对如何使用数字工具来扩大心理健康服务的获取途径感兴趣。“在美国，三分之一的人口生活在被指定为无获取区域的地区，所以他们实际上在附近没有任何心理健康专业人员。即使你住在有很多治疗师的大城市，它通常也不在保险范围内，而且可能非常昂贵。”
So a few years back, China team began thinking about how to build a digital tool that would make mental health care radically accessible. They experimented with video games before landing on the idea of WoBOT, a chatbot guide who could take users through exercises based on cognitive behavioral therapy, which helps people interrupt and reframe negative thought patterns.
所以几年前，中国团队开始思考如何建立一个数字工具，使心理健康服务变得彻底可及。他们在落地WoBOT的想法之前尝试了视频游戏，WoBOT是一个聊天机器人向导，可以引导用户进行基于认知行为疗法的练习，这有助于人们打断和重构负面思维模式。
Robot is not even trying to pass the terrain test. It's very transparently a robot. It's represented by a little robot avatar. And part of its personality is that it's curious about human feelings, like a student learning a foreign language. I think he's somewhere between Kermit the Frog, like circa 1980, and Spock. Spock who's always trying to, you know, struggle with his human emotions. As Darcy's team built a prototype and started watching people interact with Wobot, right away they could tell something interesting was happening.
机器人甚至没有试图通过图灵测试。它非常透明地是一个机器人。它由一个小机器人头像代表。它个性的一部分是它对人类情感感到好奇，就像一个学习外语的学生。“我认为他介于1980年左右的科米蛙和斯波克之间。斯波克总是试图，你知道，与他的人类情感作斗争。”当达西的团队建立了一个原型并开始观察人们与Wobot互动时，他们立刻就能看出一些有趣的事情正在发生。
They noticed that if Wobot didn't check in for a day or two, people would reach out. People were saying things like, Wobot, where were you? I need you to check in on me every day. Just like with Eliza, people were forming emotional connections with the program. They liked interacting with Wobot and relied on it. People, when we spoke to them, would say, look, I know this is just a chap but like I know this isn't anything but at the same time it feels like this fun little dude checking in on me. And so people were willing to just go with the suspended reality. They were effectively stepping into this kind of fictional world and it made it playful and fun. I've spent some time with robot and I feel the same way.
他们注意到，如果Wobot一两天没有签到，人们就会主动联系。人们会说这样的话：“Wobot，你去哪了？我需要你每天检查我。”就像伊莉莎一样，人们正在与程序建立情感联系。他们喜欢与Wobot互动并依赖它。“当我们与人们交谈时，人们会说，‘看，我知道这只是一个聊天机器人，我知道这什么都不是，但与此同时，它感觉就像这个有趣的、检查我的小家伙。’”所以人们愿意顺应这种悬浮的现实。他们实际上正在步入这种虚构的世界，这使它变得有趣和好玩。我和机器人待了一段时间，我也感觉一样。
It's like texting back and forth with a relentlessly positive and sweet little cartoon character. It offers high fives and sends you gifts. It feels less like a human therapist leading me to deep insights and more like a tiny personal cheerleader I can carry around in my pocket. A tiny personal cheerleader doesn't sound very dystopian. No, it doesn't. But I mean, of course,
这就像与一个极其积极和可爱的小卡通人物来回发短信。它提供击掌并给你送礼物。它感觉不像一个引导我进行深刻洞察的人类治疗师，更像是一个我可以随身携带在口袋里的小型个人啦啦队长。一个小型的个人啦啦队长听起来并不太反乌托邦。不，确实不是。但我的意思是，当然，
Wilbot raises tough questions about tech more broadly. If chatbots are built with nefarious intentions, they can do stuff like detect and manipulate human feelings. They can fool humans into thinking they're people. I have anxiety about this kind of tech misapplied, like anything else, like a surgeon's scalpel. This can be a tool that helps people survive and it can also be a weapon. And with global bot in particular, there are other issues too, around privacy and safety and even thornier stuff.
Wilbot提出了关于技术的更广泛的棘手问题。如果聊天机器人是出于邪恶目的而构建的，它们可以做诸如检测和操纵人类情感之类的事情。它们可以愚弄人类，让他们认为它们是人。我对这种被误用的技术感到焦虑，就像任何其他东西一样，比如外科医生的手术刀。这可以是一个帮助人们生存的工具，它也可以是一个武器。对于全球机器人，还有其他问题，围绕隐私和安全，甚至更棘手的事情。
Like, is this tool a digital bandaid that somehow enables the status quo? Meaning, the situation we're in now, where the vast majority of people don't have access to high-quality, comprehensive mental health care. Darcy is clear that she does not see Wobot as a replacement for talk therapy. And she says her team is always thinking and talking about those ethical questions. It's something we always keep an eye on, but I think, you know, the potential for good, just so much outweighs the risk right now. Darcy thought about this a lot when WoBOT first launched. They'd been working in relative obscurity, and then suddenly their numbers began to climb. Quickly, within the first five days,
比如，这个工具是一个数字创可贴，以某种方式维持了现状吗？意思是，我们现在所处的这种情况，绝大多数人无法获得高质量、全面的心理健康服务。达西明确表示，她不认为Wobot是谈话治疗的替代品。她说她的团队一直在思考和讨论那些伦理问题。“这是我们一直关注的事情，但我认为，你知道，目前向善的潜力远远超过了风险。”达西在WoBOT首次推出时对此思考了很多。他们一直在相对默默无闻地工作，然后突然间他们的数字开始攀升。很快，在最初的五天内，
they had 50,000 users. Wilbot was exchanging millions of messages with people each week. And I remember going home after our first day and sitting down at my kitchen table and having the realization that Wilbot on his first day of launch had more conversations with people
他们拥有了50,000名用户。Wilbot每周与人们交换数百万条信息。“我记得第一天结束后回家，坐在厨房桌子旁，意识到Wilbot在发布的第一天与人们进行的对话”
than a therapist could have in a lifetime. You know, it just really hit home. Joseph Weisenbaum eventually retired from MIT, but he continued speaking out against the dangers of AI until he died in 2008 at the age of 85. For a while, he became a go-to critic if a TV program needed someone to cast out on some new technology. For example, here he is in a segment about computers and schools, criticizing the tendency to reduce every human problem to a technological one. It's a very dangerous attitude. It can't help but destroy our culture if it ever becomes co-leaf victorious. And while he was an important humanist thinker, a guy way ahead of his time in many ways, some people felt like he went too far.
“比治疗师一生中能进行的对话还要多。”你知道，这真的触动了心弦。约瑟夫·魏岑鲍姆最终从麻省理工学院退休，但他继续反对人工智能的危险，直到2008年去世，享年85岁。有一段时间，如果电视节目需要有人对某项新技术表示怀疑，他成了首选的批评者。例如，这是他在一个关于计算机和学校的片段中，批评将每一个人类问题简化为技术问题的倾向。“这是一种非常危险的态度。如果它真的变得胜利，它不可避免地会摧毁我们的文化。”虽然他是一位重要的人文主义思想家，在许多方面都走在时代前列，但有些人觉得他走得太远了。
Pamela McCordock knew Wyzenbaum over several decades. She's the one who conducted the interview you heard with him earlier in the story. And she says he burned a lot of bridges in the AI community and became almost a caricature of himself towards the end. She describes being at a conference in Austria, where Weisenbaum was also in attendance. At one point he got up and delivered what had become his usual tirade. We must not use computers. The German Army used computers and looked what's going to happen.
帕梅拉·麦科德克认识魏岑鲍姆几十年了。她就是你在故事前面听到的对他进行采访的人。她说他在人工智能社区烧毁了许多桥梁，到最后几乎成了他自己的讽刺画。她描述了在奥地利参加的一次会议，魏岑鲍姆也出席了。有一次他站起来，发表了他那套惯常的抨击。“我们绝不能使用计算机。德国军队使用了计算机，看看会发生什么。”
Well, I happened to be sitting next to a young German artist, and he looked at me and he said very quietly, the German army uses knives and forks. Let us not use knives and forks. Well, I had to put my hand over my mouth to keep from laughing. And Wiesenbaum also may have missed something that Darcy was just talking about with Wilbot.
“好吧，我碰巧坐在一位年轻的德国艺术家旁边，他非常安静地看着我说：‘德国军队使用刀叉。让我们不要使用刀叉。’好吧，我不得不把手捂在嘴上以免笑出来。”魏岑鲍姆也可能错过了一些达西刚才谈到的关于Wilbot的事情。
The idea that humans engage in a kind of play when we interact with chatbots. We're not necessarily being fooled, we're just fascinated to see ourselves reflected back in these intelligent machines. That was my experience chatting with Woolbot and was probably true for Eliza too. Also, you know, I was gonna say about the Eliza
人类在与聊天机器人互动时进行的一种游戏。我们不一定是被愚弄了，我们只是着迷于看到自己在这些智能机器中被反射出来。那是我与Woolbot聊天的经历，对于伊莉莎来说可能也是如此。还有，你知道，我要说的是关于伊莉莎
and the, you know, this story about his secretary and stuff. Here's Miriam Weisenbaum again. And I want to be clear, she had many lovely things to say about her dad in our conversation that he was brilliant and insightful and funnier than people realized. But she also had this to say about the secretary's story. I always heard that just really kind of soaked in arrogance, like how could she be so stupid to think that, you know, that this is actually a meaningful communication, you know, here you have somebody who so needs a landing pad for her feelings that she's willing to embrace it, right?
以及，你知道，这个关于他的秘书的故事之类的。这是米里亚姆·魏岑鲍姆再次说道。我想明确一点，她在我们的谈话中对她的父亲有很多可爱的评价，说他才华横溢、富有洞察力，而且比人们意识到的更有趣。但她也对秘书的故事说了这样的话：“我总是觉得那真的有点傲慢，她怎么会那么蠢，认为，你知道，这实际上是一种有意义的交流，你知道，这里有一个人，她非常需要一个情感的着陆点，以至于她愿意拥抱它，对吧？”
And he totally misses that. He totally misses the human need and instead speaks of it as, you know, just evidence of this person's stupidity, rather than evidence of their humanity. I think we're all a little like Dr. Weisenbaum's secretary now. We're living in this highly automated world. We have these little computers in our pockets that we can talk to, and we're under no illusion that they really understand us, but they still captivate us, and we still rely on them. To tell us the weather, and how to get to where we want to go, and maybe even on occasion to ask us if we're doing okay.
“而他完全错过了这一点。他完全错过了人类的需求，反而将其说成是，你知道，只是这个人愚蠢的证据，而不是他们人性的证据。”我想我们现在都有一点像魏岑鲍姆博士的秘书了。我们生活在这个高度自动化的世界里。我们的口袋里有这些我们可以交谈的小计算机，我们并没有幻想它们真的理解我们，但它们仍然吸引着我们，我们仍然依赖它们。告诉我们天气，告诉我们如何到达我们想去的地方，甚至偶尔问我们是否还好。
Coming up after the break, a recent development in natural language processing that would make Joseph Weisenbaum very nervous. So I'm back in the studio with Delaney Hall, and you've got more to tell us about some interesting stuff that's happened with natural language processing in just the past year. Yeah, a lot of interesting stuff has happened just recently. So as I was interviewing people for this story, I was talking with computer scientists and historians, and we were talking about Wiesembaum and his legacy,
休息过后，我们将介绍自然语言处理领域的一项最新进展，这会让约瑟夫·魏森鲍姆（Joseph Weisenbaum）感到非常不安。现在我回到了演播室，和德莱尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）在一起，你还有更多关于过去一年自然语言处理领域发生的有趣事情要告诉我们。是的，最近确实发生了很多有趣的事情。在为这个故事采访人们时，我与计算机科学家和历史学家进行了交谈，我们谈到了魏森鲍姆和他的遗产，
and these fears he had about chatbots fooling people. And totally I'm prompted, a couple people brought up this one recent development in natural language processing. It's something that's called GPT-2. So GPT-2 stands for generalized pre-trained transformer. I can never remember what it stands for. So Melanie Mitchell, one of the computer scientists I spoke with, is close.
以及他对于聊天机器人欺骗人类的担忧。在完全没有提示的情况下，几个人提到了自然语言处理领域最近的一项进展。它被称为GPT-2。GPT-2代表“生成式预训练Transformer”。我总是记不住它代表什么。所以我采访的计算机科学家之一梅兰妮·米切尔（Melanie Mitchell）对此很了解。
It stands for generative pre-Train Transformer 2. And it's this relatively new neural network that generates incredibly convincing text. It's somebody described it as a mouth without a brain, which is a good statement. And the way that GPT-2 works is that you can input a word or a sentence or a paragraph. The program then generates text based on that input. It basically conjures up a whole coherent piece of writing based on just a few words that you give it. It is this giant neural network that is trained on a huge corpus of text to predict the next
它代表“生成式预训练Transformer 2”。这是一个相对较新的神经网络，可以生成令人难以置信的逼真文本。有人将其描述为“没有大脑的嘴”，这是一个很好的说法。GPT-2的工作方式是，你可以输入一个单词、一个句子或一个段落。程序随后会根据该输入生成文本。它基本上可以根据你提供的几个词，变戏法般地写出一整篇连贯的文章。这是一个巨大的神经网络，它在海量的文本语料库上进行训练，以预测下一个
word in a sentence or a paragraph given the preceding text. Here's Brian Christian, who we also heard from in the story. You get what appear to be plausible, if very slightly weird screenplays and, you know, news bulletins and chat message histories and all sorts of things. Okay, so I'm having a hard time picturing that. So what are some examples of the type of text that generates? Like, why and how is it so convincing? So the example that kind of broke the internet when all of this first came out
句子或段落中的单词。这是我们在故事中也听到的布莱恩·克里斯蒂安（Brian Christian）。你会得到看起来很合理，尽管有点奇怪的剧本、新闻简报、聊天记录以及各种各样的东西。好吧，我很难想象。那么它生成的文本类型有哪些例子呢？为什么以及它是如何做到如此逼真的？所以，当这一切刚出来时，那个在互联网上引起轰动的例子
was this fake news story about unicorns and the Andes. It must have missed that one. What's notable? Yeah, I know. So this will sort of help you understand a little bit better kind of how it works I think. So the prompt that GPT-2 was given, and so this was a couple of sentences that were written by a human and given to the machine, and I guess I should be clear, this was written in the style of a news story. That was intentional. So the prompt was, quote,
是关于独角兽和安第斯山脉的假新闻故事。我一定错过了那个。有什么值得注意的吗？是的，我知道。所以这会让你更好地理解它是如何工作的。GPT-2得到的提示，也就是由人类编写并提供给机器的几句话，我想我应该说明一下，这是以新闻报道的风格写的。这是故意的。所以提示是，引用：
in a shocking finding, scientists discovered a herd of unicorns living in a remote, previously unexplored valley in the Andes Mountains. Even more surprising to the researchers was the fact that the unicorn spoke perfect English. Okay, so a human wrote those sentences and then fed them to the machine. And so what did the machine spit back out? So totally independently, based on those sentences, this is what GPT2 generated.
“在一个令人震惊的发现中，科学家们在安第斯山脉一个偏远、此前未被探索的山谷中发现了一群独角兽。更让研究人员惊讶的是，这些独角兽说着一口流利的英语。”好吧，所以是一个人写了这些句子，然后喂给了机器。那么机器吐出了什么呢？完全独立地，基于这些句子，这就是GPT-2生成的。
And it actually goes on for quite a while, but I'll redo the first few lines just because they're amazing. It goes, the scientists named the population after their distinctive horn, Ovid's unicorn. These four horned silver white unicorns were previously unknown to science. Now, after almost two centuries, the mystery of what sparked this odd phenomenon is finally solved. Dr. Jorge Perez, an evolutionary biologist from the University of La Paz, and several other companions were exploring the Andes mountains when they found a small valley with no humans or animals. Perez noticed that the valley had what appeared to be a natural fountain
它实际上持续了很长一段时间，但我会重读前几行，因为它们太神奇了。它写道：“科学家们以它们独特的角为这个种群命名，即奥维德独角兽。这些四角银白色的独角兽此前不为科学界所知。现在，经过近两个世纪，这个奇怪现象背后的谜团终于解开了。拉巴斯大学的进化生物学家豪尔赫·佩雷斯（Jorge Perez）博士和几位同伴在探索安第斯山脉时，发现了一个没有人类或动物的小山谷。佩雷斯注意到山谷里有一个看起来像是天然喷泉的东西，
surrounded by two peaks of rock and silver snow. And so it goes on for a few more paragraphs, but Roman a machine, a machine wrote that, a machine. And added all the detail about Dr. Perez and the University of La Paz and everything. That's just from the machine. I know. I know. And it's like, there's a couple things that really stand out to me when I'm reading it. And the first, of course, is that, you know, the sentences are coherent. Like, if you told me a human wrote them,
周围环绕着两座岩石和银色积雪的山峰。”它还继续写了几个段落，但罗曼，是一台机器，一台机器写了这些，一台机器。而且添加了关于佩雷斯博士和拉巴斯大学以及所有的一切细节。那完全来自机器。我知道。我知道。当我读到它时，有几件事真的让我印象深刻。首先，当然是，你知道，句子是连贯的。就像，如果你告诉我是一个人写的，
I would not doubt you. Yeah, neither would I. That's incredible. And then it has those details, like, the names and the location of the university, which line up, right, with the pro. Right, right. And then, the other thing it does is that it,
我不会怀疑你。是的，我也不会。这太不可思议了。然后它有那些细节，比如大学的名字和位置，这与提示相符，对吧？对，对。然后，它做的另一件事是，它
it does this pretty convincing job of mimicking the format of a news article. So it starts with like lead sentences, they give you the most crucial information, and only then does it begin to tell the story of how the discovery unfolded. Wow. It's so cool. I mean almost can't even make sense of how how real that feels. I mean, this is pretty silly with unicorns and the anis, but I mean, I imagine, you know,
它在模仿新闻文章格式方面做得非常逼真。所以它以导语开头，给你最关键的信息，然后才开始讲述发现过程的故事。哇。太酷了。我的意思是，我几乎无法理解它感觉有多真实。我的意思是，这对于独角兽和安第斯山脉来说很傻，但我的意思是，我想，你知道，
this is making people nervous that a computer can generate this convincing of text that is if it came from a human. Yeah, yeah, absolutely. So the company that created the program called OpenAI released this paper and it had various examples of text generated by this neural net. And it caused a huge stir online, partly because it did such a good job, and partly because it made people immediately nervous. Like the idea that this text is so convincing
这让人们感到紧张，因为计算机可以生成如此逼真的文本，就像它来自人类一样。是的，是的，绝对是。所以创建这个程序的公司OpenAI发布了这篇论文，其中有这个神经网络生成的各种文本示例。它在网上引起了巨大的轰动，部分原因是它做得太好了，部分原因是它让人们立即感到紧张。就像这种文本如此逼真的想法
gets back to that idea that we talked about in the episode, which is like, will people know this was written by a machine? And because it generated a very convincing and totally fake news article, people are worrying that the tool could supercharge the spread of misinformation on the internet.
回到了我们在这一集中谈到的那个想法，即：人们会知道这是机器写的吗？因为它生成了一篇非常逼真且完全虚假的新闻文章，人们担心这个工具可能会加剧错误信息在互联网上的传播。
Right. I mean, so what do you do? Like, once you make a thing like that, how do you make sure it doesn't do that? How do you make sure it doesn't, isn't used for nefarious ends? So, the way that OpenAI approached it was when they, when they first released news about it. They said, we've made this thing. Here are some examples of the text it
对。我的意思是，那你该怎么办？就像，一旦你制造了这样的东西，你如何确保它不会那样做？你如何确保它不会被用于邪恶的目的？所以，OpenAI的处理方式是，当他们第一次发布关于它的消息时。他们说，我们制造了这个东西。这里有一些它生成的文本示例。
generates. It is extremely convincing. And because of that, we're not going to actually release the code. It's too dangerous. Whoa. Yeah. The only thing I can see a problem with that is, is like the strisand effect. Like if you say you can't use it and don't recreate it, it just means that more people are going to try to create and use that sort of thing. I mean, it just calls more attention to it. So yeah, it did call a lot of attention to it. Here is Melanie Mitchell again. A bunch of people just jumped on them.
它极其逼真。正因为如此，我们实际上不会发布代码。这太危险了。哇。是的。我唯一能看到的问题是，就像斯特莱桑德效应（Streisand effect）。如果你说你不能使用它，不要重新创建它，这只会意味着更多的人会尝试创建和使用那种东西。我的意思是，它只是引起了更多的关注。所以是的，它确实引起了很多关注。这是梅兰妮·米切尔再次发言。一群人直接跳出来指责他们。
They were saying this is just a publicity stunt. And there were, of course, the popular press Doomsday headlines about open AI creates an AI that's so powerful, it's too dangerous to release. So basically open AI got a lot of pushback. But the whole situation also inspired this interesting conversation in the AI community about these really tough questions that they're facing now, now that they can generate what are known as deep fakes, not just in text, but in audio and video too.
他们说这只是一个宣传噱头。当然，大众媒体上出现了关于“OpenAI创造了一个太强大而无法发布的AI”的末日头条。所以基本上OpenAI受到了很多阻力。但整个情况也激发了AI社区内关于他们现在面临的这些非常棘手问题的有趣对话，现在他们可以生成所谓的“深度伪造”（deep fakes），不仅是文本，还有音频和视频。
These are really convincing computer generated pieces of media. So here's Melanie. How should people think about publishing results in AI? Is it better to publish these things and get them out there so that people can do research on how to protect or defend against them or should they not be published at all? So there was this big conversation about that. I mean, I guess I wonder like, you know, this obviously has a problem with fooling people, but you know, couldn't a human
这些是非常逼真的计算机生成的媒体片段。所以这是梅兰妮的话。人们应该如何看待发布AI研究成果？是最好发布这些东西并让它们流传出去，以便人们可以研究如何保护或防御它们，还是根本不应该发布？所以关于这个问题有很大的争论。我的意思是，我想知道，你知道，这显然在欺骗人们方面存在问题，但你知道，难道人类不能
just write an entire fake news article or a bunch of them and post online. I mean, how does GPT2 make things really all that different? That was something I asked Melanie, and she said that the issue is really scale. Like, sure, she could sit down and write a story about unicorns herself and post it online and tweet it out and try to make it go viral.
直接写一篇完整的假新闻文章或一堆文章并发布在网上吗？我的意思是，GPT-2让事情变得有什么不同？这是我问梅兰妮的问题，她说问题在于规模。就像，当然，她可以坐下来自己写一个关于独角兽的故事，发布在网上，发推特，并试图让它疯传。
But it would take time, it would take effort. And instead, GPT2 could generate literally millions of these stories very quickly. And here you can just do it automatically and generate as many of these as you want. You could put them online and somebody's going to believe them. It just makes it easy to create these things and publish them and it's hard to fight back. And the tough thing is that we're already living in an online information environment where it can be hard to sort the real from the fake. You know, here's an account that says they're the Tennessee Republican Party.
但这需要时间，需要努力。而相反，GPT-2可以非常快速地生成数百万个这样的故事。在这里，你可以自动完成它，并根据需要生成尽可能多的这些故事。你可以把它们放到网上，总有人会相信它们。它只是让创建和发布这些东西变得容易，而且很难反击。棘手的是，我们已经生活在一个在线信息环境中，很难区分真假。你知道，这里有一个账号声称他们是田纳西州共和党。
Are they? You know, here's this thing that says it's the Trump fan club of Mizzoula. Is it? You know, like, here's this person who claims they're, you know, a retired Navy SEAL. Are they? You know, we're increasingly moving into this world in which it's just really hard to make sense out of discourse on the web without being extremely scrupulous and vigilant. I mean, it seems like this generation from now on, we're going to have major media literacy
他们是吗？你知道，这里有东西声称它是米苏拉的特朗普粉丝俱乐部。是吗？你知道，这里有一个人声称他们是，你知道，退役的海军海豹突击队队员。他们是吗？你知道，我们正越来越多地进入这样一个世界，在这个世界里，如果不极其谨慎和警惕，就真的很难理解网络上的话语。我的意思是，看起来从这一代开始，我们将会有重大的媒体素养
training. I mean, it's just to be able to spot the fakes from the real thing is gonna take a whole new amount of effort in part of our brain. Yeah, it is. And to bring it back to Joseph Weisenbaum, I mean, when he first started thinking about this stuff, computers were still really rudimentary. They had about as much processing power as we have
培训。我的意思是，仅仅是为了能够从真实事物中发现假货，就需要我们大脑付出全新的努力。是的，确实如此。回到约瑟夫·魏森鲍姆，我的意思是，当他第一次开始思考这些事情时，计算机仍然非常原始。它们的处理能力大约相当于我们今天
in like a parking meter today, which is to say they couldn't do much, but today it's this totally different story. How do we survive this coming reality in which you can produce, for all intents and purposes, touring test-passing content that espouses whatever viewpoint you happen to want, like infinitely at scale. Increasingly, these, you know, ostensibly philosophical questions of the Turing test become, you know, not merely one of the hassles of everyday life, but one of, I think, the more pressing questions affecting us at kind of this moment in history.
在停车计时器里的水平，也就是说它们做不了什么，但今天情况完全不同了。我们如何在这个即将到来的现实中生存，在这个现实中，你可以生产出实际上通过图灵测试的内容，支持你碰巧想要的任何观点，就像无限规模一样。越来越多地，这些，你知道，表面上是图灵测试的哲学问题，变得，你知道，不仅仅是日常生活中的麻烦之一，而且我认为，是这个历史时刻影响我们的更紧迫的问题之一。
Well, so it seems like wise and wise, you know, made been ahead of his time, but dead on. It's interesting because I think he sounded to many people in his time, alarmist, but increasingly the questions that he was raising seem very, very relevant. I find myself wishing that we had both Turing and Wiesenbaum by our side in the coming decade because I think we need all the perspective we can get. 99% Invisible was produced this week Week By Our Senior Editor Delaney Hall, Mix Intek Production By Shereef Yusuf, Music By Sean Real. Katie Mingle Is Our Senior Producer Kurt Colstad Is The Digital Director.
好吧，所以看起来魏森鲍姆，你知道，可能走在了时代的前面，但完全正确。这很有趣，因为我认为他在当时听起来对许多人来说是危言耸听，但越来越多的他提出的问题似乎非常非常相关。我发现自己希望在未来十年里，图灵和魏森鲍姆都能站在我们身边，因为我认为我们需要尽可能多的视角。99% Invisible本周由我们的高级编辑德莱尼·霍尔制作，谢里夫·优素福（Shereef Yusuf）混音和技术制作，肖恩·里尔（Sean Real）配乐。凯蒂·明格尔（Katie Mingle）是我们的高级制作人，库尔特·科尔斯塔德（Kurt Colstad）是数字总监。
The rest of the team is Emmett Fitzgerald, Joe Rosenberg, Chris Baroube, Vivian Leigh, Avery Trollfmann, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. Special thanks This Week To Katie Mingle, who first came up with this idea to do a story about Eliza. Thanks also to Dr. Elena Books, who has studied the ethics of AI in mental health settings. You can find a link to the paper she co-authored on our website. Thanks also to the Carnegie Mellon University Archives for letting us use the recording of Joseph Weisenbaum from the Pamela McCordock collection.
团队的其他成员是埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、克里斯·巴鲁贝（Chris Baroube）、薇薇安·李（Vivian Leigh）、艾弗里·特罗夫曼（Avery Trollfmann）、索菲亚·克拉茨克（Sophia Klatsker）和我罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。本周特别感谢凯蒂·明格尔，她首先想到了做一个关于Eliza的故事。还要感谢埃琳娜·布克斯（Elena Books）博士，她研究了心理健康环境中的AI伦理。你可以在我们的网站上找到她合著的论文链接。还要感谢卡内基梅隆大学档案馆让我们使用帕梅拉·麦科多克（Pamela McCordock）收藏的约瑟夫·魏森鲍姆的录音。
And finally, thanks to Naomi and Miriam Weisenbaum, who generously shared their memories of their father. We are a project of 91.7 KALW in San Francisco, and produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. 99% of visible is a member of radio Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative shows in all of podcasting. Support them all at RadioTopia.fm. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI Ork. We're on Instagram and read it too.
最后，感谢娜奥米（Naomi）和米里亚姆·魏森鲍姆（Miriam Weisenbaum），她们慷慨地分享了对父亲的回忆。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，在加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的市中心Radio Row制作。99% Invisible是PRX旗下RadioTopia的成员，这是一个由播客界最具创新性的节目组成的独立集体。在RadioTopia.fm支持他们。你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并加入关于该节目的讨论。你可以在推特上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@99PIorg。我们在Instagram和Reddit上也有账号。
Mars and the show at 99PI org. We're on Instagram and ready to. But our true home on the web is 99PI.org. So I remember one time when I was probably about 10 asking my dad if I could work on the computer. I asked if I could be alone, not that I knew anything at that time about the famous story of his secretary wanting to be left alone to work with Eliza. I didn't know anything about that. But I somehow knew that this computer was going to have powerful insights into people and who I was and something like that. And unbeknownst
马尔斯和节目在99PI org。我们在Instagram和Reddit上也有。但我们在网络上的真正家园是99PI.org。所以我记得有一次我大概10岁的时候问我爸爸我能不能在电脑上工作。我问我能不能一个人待着，并不是说我当时知道任何关于他的秘书想一个人留下来和Eliza一起工作的著名故事。我对此一无所知。但我不知何故知道这台电脑会对人以及我是谁有深刻的见解，诸如此类。而不为
to me, he had turned the computer on so that it operated basically as a typewriter. But I didn't know that. And so I sat down at the typewriter and I typed in, what is my sister Miriam doing right now? And I waited for a really long time and the computer didn't answer me. And then I said, what is Miriam wearing right now? Because I knew the answer to that. So I thought well then maybe the computer would too and nothing happened.
我所知，他把电脑打开了，所以它基本上是作为打字机运行的。但我不知道。所以我坐在打字机前，输入了：“我姐姐米里亚姆现在在做什么？”我等了很长时间，电脑没有回答我。然后我说：“米里亚姆现在穿什么？”因为我知道答案。所以我以为也许电脑也会知道，但什么也没发生。
And finally, I waited for a really long time. And finally, I got up and discussed and thought, this stupid computer doesn't know shit. Yeah. Radio tapio. From PRX. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
最后，我等了很长时间。最后，我失望地站起来，心想，这台愚蠢的电脑什么都不知道。是的。Radio Topia。来自PRX。来自PRX。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。